[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur ce live twitch
consacré à notre mastercl diversité
égalité et en direct sur notre campus de
trs Paris wouest j'en profite pour
saluer nos collègues et amis des campus
3S de Lyon Bordeaux Nantes et puis
naturellement notre futur campus de trs
Avignon nous recevons aujourd'hui une
invitée de marque agè s bienvenue et
pour cela je suis
entouré de Tila et ravu qui est
actuellement une étudiante en 3e année
son et qui a créé un compte Instagram
qui
s'appelle femme du son et de Thomas
Breger qui est directeur des relations
internationales 3IS et référent égalité
diversité sur le campus de de Paris agès
s bienvenue bonjour bonjour à vous je
suis ravie de vous avoir enfin rejoin et
rejoint après un périple un peu long
jusqu'à vos locaux mais je suis là mais
écoutez c'est un plaisir en tout cas de
manière à vous présenter et à vous
recevoir dignement je me suis permis de
rédiger un petit mémo dont je
souhaiterais vous donner
lecture vous êtes né un un 8 décembre à
Tunis vous étudiez à l'Institut d'études
politiques de Paris vous Lena l'École
nationale d'administration en
1983 au sein de la promotion solidarité
ce qui est déjà un signe fort de votre
engagement votre carrière vous mène très
tôt au ministère de la Culture puis au
CNC le Centre national de la
cinématographie en tant que Directrice
Administrative et Financière vous
travaillez ensuite au cabinet de
plusieurs ministres de la Culture
directrice générale de la BNF aussi
Bibliothèque nationale de France puis du
centre Georg Pompidou après avoir avir
été présidente de Lina l'Institut
national de l'audiovisuel vous êtes
nommé haute fonctionnaire à l'égalité à
la diversité et à la prévention des
discriminations puis à la responsabilité
sociale des organisations auprès du
secrétaire général du ministère de la
culture forte de ce parcours culturel
passionné et socialement engagé c'est
avec un plaisir réel et un grand honneur
de vous accueillir cher agnè sal dans ce
cadre de de notre masterclass égalité
diversité
merci pour cette présentation dire en
effet que mon parcours est marqué par
une inscription très forte dans le champ
de la culture des arts des médias de
l'audiovisuel du cinéma par goût
personnel et puis aussi par conviction
de la de l'importance du rôle que jouent
ces ces discipline artistique et
culturelle dans la construction d'une
conscience citoyenne d'une conscience
démocratique d'une conscience
républicaine
et finalement le fait aujourd'hui d'être
chargé au ministère de la culture dans
l'ensemble du champ culturel et
artistique publ mais aussi privé de ces
de la promotion de ces valeurs si
importantes que sont la diversité au
sens de la prévention des
discriminations et l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes ma fois c'est une
poursuite qui me semble avec un peu de
recul assez assez logique et assez assez
formidable de ce que j'ai pu faire
auparavant à la direction générale à la
tête d'un certain nombre d'institutions
culturelles qui ont été qui ont été
rappelées je vais commencer par une
première question c'est quelle périmètre
souhaitez-vous définir durant cette cet
échange sur l'égalité et la
diversité alors le périmètre sur lequel
je travaille maintenant depuis à peu
près 5 ans et et demi presque 6 ans au
ministère de la Culture est un périmètre
que j'ai moi-même et c'est une chance
défini comme étant extrêmement large
extrêmement
extensif au départ on m'avait demandé de
m'intéresser plutôt au sujet de
l'égalité professionnelle et de la
diversité dans le périmètre restreint du
ministère de la Culture lui-même et de
ses établissements publics vous savez
peut-être que au sein du ministère de la
Culture euh on a un certain nombre
d'agents qui travaillent en
administration centrale en
administration déconcentrée les
Direction régionale des affaires
culturelles et puis on a tout un réseau
d'établissements publics 80 euh parmi
lesquels on trouve les grands les grands
musées l'Opéra national de Paris l'Opéra
Comique la Bibliothèque nationale de
France et cetera mais il m'a semblé très
vite que limiter le travail de prise de
conscience d'identification des
obstacles et de définition des
procédures des levier d'action en
matière de prévention des
discriminations ce travail serait trop
restreint trop limité et finalement
assez inefficace si il ne concernait que
ce périmètre d'où ma volonté tout de
suite de travailler aux enjeux d'égalité
et de diversité dans l'ensemble du champ
culturel et artistique incluant donc les
institutions qui relèvent non pas
directement de l'État mais des
collectivités
territoriales incluant également tout un
champ
euh proche du secteur proche ou
appartenant au secteur privé par exemple
dans l'industrie du cinéma de
l'audiovisuel du jeux vidéo dans les
dans le secteur de l'architecture le
l'ensemble du du champ de l'architecture
qui relève du du secteur privé dans le
secteur musical euh toutes les
entreprises qui relèvent par exemple de
l'industrie phonographique ou de de de
l'activité privée et donc l'ensemble des
des secteurs euh artistiques et
culturels sont sont concernés on a
entendu parler récemment du plan
interministériel mis en place par euh
ellisabeth bornne contre le harcèlement
scolaire euh quelles ont été euh vos
actions euh sur ce plan-là alors pas
directement dans le champ de l'éducation
nationale puisque par que bien entendu
ce sont deux ministères différents
l'éducation nationale j' ajoute
d'ailleurs un autre partenaire important
qui est le ministère de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la recherche avec lequel
on travaille beaucoup et le ministère de
la Culture qui est encore un autre une
autre administration et nous n'avons pas
nous à intervenir directement dans le
domaine des euh des établissements
scolaires qui relèvent du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale pour autant nous
avons à plusieurs titres des actions
communes pour parler plus spécifiquement
de la question du harcèlement scolaire
nous avons nous-mêmes au ministère de la
Culture un réseau de 99 établissements
d'enseignement supérieur culture qui
sont les écoles d'art les écoles
d'architecture la Fémis dont vous avez
certainement entendu parler euh les
conservatoires nationaux supérieurs de
Musique et de Danse de Paris et de Lyon
euh l'Institut national du patrimoine
l'école du LOU en donc tout un réseau
des qui maille l'ensemble du territoire
national et au sein desquels nous avons
dès les années 2018 2019 lancer des
actions assez vigoureuses parce que très
nécessaires sur
la promotion des valeurs d'égalité et de
diversité et aussi sur la un plan très
important qui se poursuit évidemment
aujourd'hui parce qu'on a jamais fini
avec ces sujets-là de prévention et de
lutte contre les violences et le
harcèlement sexuel et sexiste puisque
alors nous avons euh ces 99 écoles qui
représentent à peu près 37000 étudiantes
et étudiants et nous savons que euh dans
ces établissement les questions de
violence euh sexuelle et sexiste
existent et qu'il qu'il était donc plus
que nécessaire à pour le ministère de la
Culture et pour les directions de ces
établissements de s'emparer réellement
de ces sujets et bien au-delà des
discours des bonnes paroles des bonnes
intentions et de mettre en place toute
une série d'outils à la fois de
formation de désignation de référent et
référents de procédurees de d'enquête
interne de sanction s'il le faut de
signalement à la à la justice de
protection des des victimes et donc même
si ça n'est pas exactement le le le le
cadre dans lequel le la première
ministre a pris des mesures et la le
ministre de l'éducation nationale en
matière de harcèlement scolaire nous
avons nous-mêmes au sein de nos
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
culture un gros travail qui a déjà été
entamé mais qui doit se poursuivre sur
les notions de de harcèlement et
notamment de harcèlement sexuel et
sexiste c'est une mobilisation générale
en fait à la fois de tous les ministères
et puis également de du corps étudiant
parce que même à l'intérieur des écoles
on assiste aussi à des campagne de
promotion vraiment pour que pour libérer
la parole et cetera mais nous avons
vraiment en matière de violence sexuel
et sexiste ériger le principe de
tolérance zéro et ça n'est pas qu'un
principe qui fait bien dans le paysage
parce qu'on a quand même on arrive après
des décennies
de d'hypocrisie de lâcheté d'impuissance
où rien n'était fait on savait que ces
phénomènes de de violence sexuelle et
sexiste existaient partout peut-être pas
davantage dans le secteur culturel que
dans d'autres domaines mais pour autant
chez nous ils exist exista mais ma fois
personne ne faisait grand-chose à partir
de ces années-là et j'avoue que Mitou
nous a beaucoup aider et à portter ce ce
mouvement au niveau de d'exigence
souhaitaable nous avons vraiment mis en
place toute une série de dispositifs qui
vont quand même jusqu'à quelque chose
qui je pense en tout cas j'ai cherché je
n'ai pas trouvé n'existe pas ailleurs ni
dans d'autres
secteurs en France ni dans d'autres pays
en tout cas européen qui est le principe
d'un conditionnement de l'attribution
des aides financières publiques par le
ministère de la Culture au fait que les
structures qui sont demandeuses et
potentiellement bénéficiaires d'aide
financière de du ministère doivent pour
en bénéficier répondre à une série
d'exigences en matière de prévention et
de lutte contre les violences sexuelles
et sexistes en mettant en place
elle-même toutes toutes ces mesures et
on les y a évidemment aidé de formation
sensibilisation désignation de référents
désignation également de de procédures
protectrices et d'accompagnement des
victimes présumées et de sanction à
l'égard des
personnes dont on aura prouvé la la
culpabilité et donc ce sont des
exigences de départ qui couvrent tous
les secteurs culturel et artistique et
qui finalement impose aux structures qui
souhaitent être aidé financièrement par
le ministère de la Culture de s'être
elle-même outillée armée contre ces
dispositifs je ne veux pas dire du tout
que tout est parfait et que aujourd'hui
on ne constate aucun phénomène de ce
type mais pour autant le signal envoyé
par le ministère de la Culture est
suffisamment fort pour dire que pour
bénéficier de de subsid publ de
subvention publique B ma foi il faut
réellement prendre la mesure de ces de
ces problèmes et les traiter réellement
en tout cas visiblement les ministères
ont entendu en effet parce que nous par
exemple on a un le référent réalisation
audiovisuelle sur le campus de 3S
Bordeaux qui est un jeune réalisateur
qui a réalisé un film qui s'appelle je
te faisait confiance sur le harcèlement
scolaire parce que très tôt en fait de
sa propre expérience il s'est rendu
compte il a il a constaté vraiment un
certain nombre de voilà de de de de
phénomènes indésirabl notamment et d'un
harcèlement très fort est ce qu' lui a
donné l'idée de se de de produire et de
réaliser ce film qui a été présenté
justement dans les ministères aussi à
titre de témoignage voilà til je pense
que tu as des obligations
professionnelles donc on on te remercie
infiniment de de ta présence et de
d'avoir préparer également donc cette
cet entretien Merci à VOUS j'étais ravi
de vous rencontrer pour ce court échange
du coup d'autant plus que vous êtes dans
une filière son ouais ce qui m'intéresse
beaucoup parce que c'est une filière où
il n'y a pas encore tant de fill qui
exerc veux-tu dire quelques mots sur
femme du son ouais bah c'est du coup
c'est un voilà un compte Instagram
collectif un peu que j'ai créé en 2022
du coup j'avais je sais pas 19 ans et
c'est un compte qui met en avant le
travail de femmes qui travaillent dans
le son ça va ça les valorise dans leur
dans leur travail j'ai des interviews
j'ai des tutos je su des collaborations
avec des des marques et en bio là on
peut le voir il y a une liste et toutes
les femmes qui travaillent dans le son
peuvent s'inscrire dessus il y a marqué
il y a toutes leurs coordonnées t tous
les lieux où elles peuvent résider et
euh si des personnes ont un projet ou un
une idée de projet ils peuvent les
contacter via cette liste et euh bah
c'est sur souvent des personnes qui
recherchent la parité et la diversité
dans leur tournage surtout en tournage
parce qu'on on a de plus en plus besoin
du du 50 50 du ratio et donc voilà
d'ailleurs si vous voulez rejoindre le
collectif 5050 c'est un très bon
collectif de de l'audiovisuel un très
bon partenaire à moi et on travaille
avec 5050 justement depuis
2018 qui a été l'année phare pardon si
je dévie un peu du déroulé puisque c'est
c'est très c'est très emblématique
finalement de la manière dont on peut
travailler en s'alliant à des collectifs
à des associations qui sont évidemment
très en pointe sur ces sujets d'égalité
et de diversité et qui sont pour moi des
alliés des partenaires formidables et
avec 5050 avec le collectif 5050 nous
avons mis en place il faut le le dire
grâce à la volonté de la ministre de la
culture de l'époque Françoise Nissen et
avec le CNC avec le Centre national de
de la
cinématographie ce premier dispositif
très intéressant auquel vous faisiez
allusion antilï qui est un dispositif de
bonification des aides publiques en en
l'occurrence du soutien automatique à la
production cinématographique euh une
bonification de 15 % du soutien si le
plateau de tournage d'un long métage
enfin d'un film long métrage ou court
métrage peu importe euh si le plateau
est paritaire et nous avons énuméré une
liste de postes qui euh d'une dizaine de
postes donc et si on atteint le ratio de
50 % de ces postes occupé par des femmes
automatiquement le la le soutien
automatique mobilisé pour le tournage du
film et majoré de 15 %. et aujourd'hui
on alors que au départ avant la mise en
place de cette bonification on avait à
peine à peine 20 % des films qui
auraient pu prétendre à cette
bonification aujourd'hui je faisais le
point encore ce matin avec le le CNC on
a 34 % des films éligibles au à la
bonification alors 34 % vous me direz
c'est pas encore 50 % et c'est pas
encore 100 % non plus mais n'empêche que
la progression
il y a un vrai progrès absolument je me
permets de continuer avec des questions
qui dit égalité ne dit pas facment
diversité qu'est-ce qui est le lien
entre les deux et comment on peut
l'utiliser afin de de de de combattre
toutes les inégalité quand on dit que on
est à égalité de chanceces dans nos
sociétés aujourd'hui c'est faux parce
qu'on sait très bien que certains
certaines sont empêché par différents
facteurs qui
euh
empêche la réalisation de l'objectif de
l'idéal de l'universalisme républicain
et donc notre travail à nous c'est de
faire en sorte d'identifier les
obstacles et de prendre les mesures
prendre trouver les solutions capable de
surmonter ces difficultés et en la
matière et ça c'est ça peut être un
élément intéressant de réponse à votre
question ce que nous avons mis en place
en matière d'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes ce sont finalement des
formules des des processus des solutions
qui sont en tout cas qui peuvent être
également efficaces en matière de
traitement des autres formes d'inégalité
de discrimination ce qu'on a trouvé
comme solution pour promouvoir l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes peut tout
à fait servir à promouvoir également
l'égalité de chance l'égalité d'accès
pour les personnes qui aujourd'hui du
fait de leur origine ethnoraciale du
fait de leur orientation sexuelle ou
identité de genre du fait de leur état
de santé du fait de leur handicap du
fait d'autres facteurs sont aujourd'hui
en position défavorable par rapport à à
à d'autres d'autres composants de la
société qu'est-ce que sont des des des
faits concrets ou des actions concrets
que que que vous au niveau du ministère
vous pouvez faire et quels sont les des
actions que nous en terme de
de membres de la Société de tous les
jours qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire je
parle toujours dans le dans dans dans le
secteur de la culture on va pas on va
rester dans ce secteur là pour le moment
c'est déjà c'est déjà ambitieux en fait
la
responsabilité publique de l'État des
ministères des structures publiques me
semble extrêmement importante parce
qu'on a malgré
tout deux formes d'action à la fois une
action directe et puis une action
d'exemplarité c'estàd qu'il est très
difficile il aurait été très difficile
d'aller donner des leçons au secteur
privé par exemple aux grandes
entreprises du jeu vidéo de l'industrie
phonographique du cinéma de
l'audiovisuel pour en rester secteur qui
vous concerne plus particulièrement si
nous n'avions pas au départ pris des
mesures très radicales et très fortes
pour nos
propres structures relevant directement
du du ministère et ces mesures quelles
sont-elles c'est à la fois des mesures
de nomination et par ex exemple en terme
d'égalité femm-homme on a réalisé un
certain nombre de progrès quantifiables
qui sont chiffrés qui sont mesurables
qui sont assez significatifs par exemple
je parlais tout à l'heure des
établissements publics de la de la
culture les les grandes institutions
culturelles on en a 80 et quand on a
commencé à travailler sur ces sujets
dans les années
2017-28 on
avait à peine un peu moins même de 30 %
de femmes dirigeant ces institutions
alors même que au ministère de la
culture dans tout le périmètre il y a
plus de 50 % de femmes qui travaillent
donc on n'est pas en en panne ou en malâ
de vivier mais les établissements
publics n'étaient dirigé par des femmes
que à hauteur de moins de 30 %.
aujourd'hui en 2023 donc on a 43 % de
nos établissements publics qui sont
dirigés par des femmes on n'est pas
encore à la parité mais n'empêche que le
mouvement de nomination a été fort et
que il s'est également exercé ce
mouvement à l'égard de beaucoup de
structures culturelles œuvrant notamment
dans le champ de la création artistique
par exemple les les centres dramatiques
nationaux les scènes national les scènes
de musique actuell tout cette ce ce
réseau d'institutions culturelles qui
sont présentes dans l'ensemble du sur
l'ensemble du territoire national et qui
font vivre finalement la culture sur les
territoires donc déjà ce pouvoir de
nomination qui est fort qui est parfois
partagé avec les collectivités
territoriales mais dans lequel
évidemment le ministère de la Culture a
un rôle éminent à jouer et puis le
ministère de la Culture
distribue des montants très considérable
de de de subventions et c'est important
que le ministère il commence vraiment à
le faire s s'intéresse et s'interroge
sur la manière dont ces fonds sont
attribués ver ou pas de manière
égalitaire parce que c'est très
intéressant de se dire finalement que
les femmes pour toujours rester sur la
la la question de l'égalité les femmes
aujourd'hui dans le domaine de la
production et de la réalisation
cinématographique on en a à peu près on
a à peu près 25 25 ou 26 % en France de
femmes réalisatrices de cinéma donc
c'est pas encore on est encore très très
loin de la parité mais ça a progressé
mais si on regarde les moyens financiers
dont disposent les femmes réalisatrices
pour tourner un film de long métrage on
se rend compte que ces moyens financiers
sont encore inférieurs ça varie un peu
d'une année sur l'autre mais sont encore
inférieur d'à peu près 30 35 voire 40 %
au moyens financiers dont disposent les
les hommes réalisateurs pour tourner
leur film il est évident que le film que
vous tournez avec avec un budget
inférieur de 40 % n'est pas le même que
celui qu' vous tournez avec un budget
supérieur de 40 % et donc se dire que
c'est cette question des moyens
financiers attribués joue un rôle
important dans la visibilité dans la
reconnaissance dans la manière d'être
exposé au regard du du public c'est
quelque chose de très fort de même dans
l'attribution de subvention publiqu aux
compagnies de théâtre de musique de
danse sur l'ensemble du territoire
veillz à ce que les femmes qui dirigent
ces compagnies disposent de budgets
identiques ou en tout cas proche
similaire à ceux dont disposent les
hommes qui dirigent ces compagnies c'est
quelque chose de très important ce qui
je trouve très intéressant ou
souvent très difficilement aussi à
quantifier c'est la relation ou le lien
qui a l'égalité avec le pouvoir je veux
dire pouvoir ça peut être pouvoir
politique pouvoir économique
le pouvoir en général du genre dans
certaines entreprises dans certaines
lieux culturels ou voilà ça peut prendre
plusieurs différentes formes comment
vous voyez le le lien comment il a
évolué et comment il va évoluer encore
dans le futur quand on travaille sur
l'égalité notamment femme homme mais
c'est également transposable à la
volonté de
promouvoir des personnes pour l'instant
ter du fait justement de leur origine
étoraciale orientation sexuelle et
cetera finalement on se dit que on
va casser
un système et même une systémie
d'inégalité
un schéma dans lequel finalement le
patriarcat était prévalent il a été
pendant très très très longtemps et
patriarcat mais
également
possession du
pouvoir au sein d'un petit d'un petit
plus ou moins petit groupe de personnes
caractérisé par leur leur origine ce
sont en règle générale donc je l'ai dit
des hommes des hommes blancs des hommes
hétérosexuels plutôt plutôt qu'un cas ou
sexagénère qui détenait qui détiennent
encore un peu le pouvoir le pouvoir de
décision le pouvoir de FA le pouvoir de
de concevoir de créer de produire dans
nos secteurs culturels et artistiques et
donc à partir du moment où on érige en
principe le fait que l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes et puis également
les autres formes de diversité doit pré
doit
prévaloir on s'attaque finalement à une
forteresse qui
est qui est dure à conquérir qui est
celle justement du pouvoir détenu par
ceux qui auront à un moment donné et le
plus tôt possible mes yeux en tout cas
qui auront à le partager ce pouvoir mais
je pense que les évolutions assez
récentes hein les évolutions de la
société les attentes sociétales font
qu'il est
aujourd'hui de plus en plus difficile de
prétendre que le combat pour l'égalité
le combat pour la diversité ne sont pas
des exigences démocratiques urgentes
immédiate et que finalement on peut
c'est un discours qu'on nous a seriné
pendant très longtemps on peut se
contenter d'attendre que spontanément
naturellement l'égalité notamment entre
les femmes et les hommes prenne toute sa
place dans la société c'est faux et en
réalité sans mesures
euh contraignante sans mesures positives
euh en la matière on sait pertinemment
que à moins d'attendre encore de siècles
et on n' pas le temps d'attendre et on
ne veut pas attendre ces évolutionsl ne
se feront pas naturellement comment on
peut briser
ces
stéréotype billet souvent inconscient je
je la mets parce que je pense qu'on a
tous on est tous grandi dans un certain
système de billet qu'on peut pas juste
enlever comme ça comment vous vous vous
pensez qu'on peut briser ces ces
stéréotypes sans sans finir dans dans la
cota ou dans dire vous devez faire ça ou
pas autrement pour laisser une certaine
liberté créative alors effectivement on
a deux principes qui semblent qui
semblent s'opposer le principe sacroin
de la liberté d'expression de la liberté
de création et personne personne ni ici
ni ailleurs ne veut
entraver ce serait une catastrophe la
liberté de création et puis en parallèle
il y a ces obstacles dont on parle
depuis tout à l'heure qui empêche
certaines et certains d'accéder à la
simple possibilité de créer de se
produire d'être connu d'être vu d'être
reconnu et il faut arriver à concilier
ces deux ces deux ces deux volontés
alors s'agissant justement des des
stéréotypes il y a plusieurs types de
plusieurs sortes de réponses déjà d'une
part qui écrit les récits qui par
exemple est scénariste qui
euh est auteur ou autrice de euh de de
de de pièces de théâtre qui vont être
donné qui euh rédige les les les scripts
des des des films des séries télévisé et
cetera et donc déjà introduire de la
diversité dans la population de celles
et de ceux qui ont vocation à raconter à
écrire c'est déjà une étape fondamentale
et non seulement c'est une étape
fondamentale en terme d'égalité donc une
valeur démocratique éminente mais c'est
également une valeur fondamentale parce
que il me semble et j'en suis vraiment
moi intimement convaincu que donner la
parole donner la plume si on peut dire
dire à une diversité
de personnes qui vont raconter des
histoires différentes du fait justement
de leur histoire personnelle de du lieu
dont dont elle d'où ell parlent est un
facteur formidable d'enrichissement de
diversification de de comment dire de
d'imaginaire renouveler plutôt que de
rester finalement toujours dans une
espèce d'entre soi où ce sont les mêmes
les mêmes issus des mêmes études des
mêmes villes des mêmes quartiers qui
vont raconter des histoires et qui vont
ensuite donner lieu à des films à des
séries à des documentaires à des pièces
de théâtre et cetera donc déjà faire en
sorte que au départ de l'écriture on est
cette diversité et puis on dit les rôles
ne sont pas écrits peut-être mais d'un
autre côté tout rôle a vocation à être
incarné par toute personne quand par
exemple on se rend compte au travers de
l'étudeinégalité que les personnes
d'origine
ethnoraciale différentes euh avaient et
sans doute ont encore aujourd'hui dans
les dans les films tournés en en France
des rôles qui sont quand même sacrément
assignés on se dit que rien n'empêche
que dans par exemple une série télévisée
on confie le rôle je dis n'importe quoi
de du médecin de l'avocat ou de
l'avocate de l'homme ou de la femme
politique à une personne qui justement
est du d'une qui n'est pas blanche rien
rien ne l'empêche à priori et pourtant
on ne le fait pas on ne le fait pas
parce qu'on garde toujours des en soi
des stéréotypes qui semblent
finalement extrêmement rigides et vous
avez raison de dire qu'ils ne sont pas
toujours conscients ces stéréotypes donc
il faut les briser il faut les rendre
enfin il faut en être conscient déjà et
il faut les briser pour dire que
finalement toute personne a vocation à
occuper ses rôles qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire pour que les gens se rend compte
que la diversité ça aussi un atout très
positif en terme professionnel et en
terme personnel c'est c'est quoi les
atouts par exemple qu'on pourrait qu'on
devrait mettre en avant pour que tout le
monde se rend compte que de base c'est
c'est c'est ça peut être beaucoup mieux
c'est pas juste quelque chose qu'il faut
faire parce que on me le demande ou
parce que c'est une valeur républicaine
mais parce que ça apporte vraiment
quelque chose ah ça ça on en est mais
vraiment intimement convaincu alors pour
parvenir à cette prise de conscience là
il y a pas mal de de d'outils alors
évidemment le premier c'est quand même
l'éducation vous me direz qu'il échappe
cet outil là assez largement au
ministère de la Culture parce que
l'éducation ça commence ça commence à
l'école ça commence dans les familles et
on se dit que c'est déjà là que devrait
se jouer un certain nombre de d'actions
positives pour prouver que l'autre
finalement l'autre avec un grand A
quelle que soit cette autre n'est pas un
danger n'est pas une menace mais au
contraire est un est une richesse est un
est un facteur de de d'ouverture de
dialogue de
générosité je vous dis enfin l'état
actuel de la société n'est pas
complètement le reflet de ce que je dis
là aujourd'hui mais pour autant c'est
quand même un objectif que je pense nous
devrions toutes et tous poursuivre mais
dire que c'est un que c'est l'éducation
qui est à la base de tout c'est vrai
mais en même temps c'est un peu
dangereux parce que ça risque de nous
dédoiner de d'actions positives qui n
relève que de nous parce dire finalement
c'est à l'école que tout se passe oui
d'accord mais nous dans les secteurs
culturels et artistiques on n pas de
prise sur l'enseignement sur l'école et
pourtant nous avons une responsabilité
et donc on se dit que on a des actions à
conduire on a évoqué quelques-uns des
outils il y a l'action de la formation
de la sensibilisation qui est très très
efficace hein quand on a par exemple
dérouler dans un domaine bien
particulier qui est la la prévention des
violences sexuelles et sexistes toute
une action de formation avec des notions
juridiques mais des actions également
des des notions extrêmement pratiques on
a formé euh dans la la le le champ
culturel euh du ministère de la Culture
plus de 9500 personnes en 2 ans ce qui
est énorme parce qu'on a eu la volonté
de le faire je peux vous dire que les
personnes qui sortaient des sessions de
formation bah n'étaient plus exactement
les mêmes que celles qui entraient dans
les stages donc l'action de formation
elle est elle est elle est elle est
puissante quand elle est bien faite
évidemment elle est elle est puissante
et puis il y a également heureusement
des rôles modèles qui peuvent jouer un
rôle extrêmement
positif à la fois par leur action dans
les entreprises dans leur action de
création artistique qui peuvent prouver
que finalement cette diversité qu'on
qu'on a vraiment en tête comme une vertu
cardinale quand elle s'incarne quand
elle s'incarne dans une œuvre quand elle
s'incarne dans une œuvre d'art dans un
dans dans dans un film dans une
exposition dans un bâtiment qu'un
architecte ou une architecte construit
elle a finalement une valeur d'exemple
positif qui entraîne qui embarque et
donc c'est pour ça que je crois beaucoup
à la force de la euh de la culture et
des différentes incarnations de la
culture pour convaincre que cette
diversité est un est un atout formidable
de même que dans une structure quel
qu'elle soit culturel en particulier le
fait d'avoir à égalité des femmes et des
hommes d'avoir des profils différents
qui viennent
de lieux de de vie différent qui
viennent d'histoire personnell
différente ça ne peut qu'enrichir le
discours et je travaille beaucoup avec
les entreprises du jeu vidéo qui
explique enfin qui comprennent et c'est
très juste que quand on confie le
pouvoir créatif dans le le le la
création même de jeux vidéo à des
équipes qui qui sont composé à 100 % de
jeunes hommes trentenaires hétérosexuel
bah forcément on a à l'arrivée un jeu
qui n'est pas forcément représentatif ni
à l'image des joueurs et des joueuses
qui vont qui vont ensuite l'utiliser et
donc introduire de la diversité y
compris dans ces équipes créatives ne
peut qu'avoir un effet positif sur le le
produit fini qui est le jeu mais c'est
vrai dans toute production culturel et
donc avoir un impact également positif
en terme de qualité intrinsèque et en
terme de capacité à toucher des publics
qui s'y reconnaîtront bien mieux et bien
davantage quels sont les conseils qui
vous pourriez donner à à une institution
comme la nôtre mais pour moi plus
important encore c'est quels sont les
conseils que vous pourriez donner au aux
étudiants aux futurs jeunes
professionnels ou aux jeunes
professionnels ou aux futurs étudiants
qui qui vont venir étudier parce que
c'est un
peu j'aime pas trop le dire comme ça
mais c'est on compte un peu sur eux
parce que c'est eux qui vont créer
leur la nouvelle vague du travail et
comment ça va être fait c'est quoi les
conseils que vous pourriez donner je
disant aux étudiants et peut-être aussi
un peu déjà à l'école à l'école il faut
diversifier les viviers il faut faire en
sorte de tendre vers je sais bien que ça
n'est pas facile mais tendre vers par
exemple l'égalité fille garçon au sein
des effectifs étudiants pour préparer
justement cette relève euh et la la
ministre de la Culture va bientôt
annoncer des des mesures tout à fait
intéressantes autour de ce concept de
relève faire en sorte que finalement ce
soit d'autres qui viennent diriger des
institutions des structures euh
culturelles et artistiques donc pour
préparer cette relève il faut évidemment
que nos écoles cette école si également
se préoccupe de divers de diversifier en
matière des de de
de genre mais également en terme de
diversité sociale de diversité
géographique c'est vivier de de
recrutement et puis faire en sorte une
fois qu'on est à l'école de veiller à ce
que
euh le cursus que vous proposez soit
facilité pour pour celles et pour ceux
qui sont peut-être en non pas en
décalage mais en plus grande difficulté
parce que en vulnérabilité économique
parce que en difficulté je je je sais
pas mais en difficulté par exemple à
pouvoir se loger vous voyez des éléments
très matériels mais qui peuvent peser
lourd sur le déroulement d'un cursus
d'étude et puis également enfin le
conseil mais il est facile à donner hein
peut-être plus difficile à suivre aux
étudiantes et aux étudiants
c'est ne vous interdisez rien quand vous
êtes j'aiété ravi d'avoir til tout à fa
tout à l'heure à à mes côtés quand vous
êtes une fille toutes les filières y
compris les plus techniques et les plus
masculines aujourd'hui vous sont
ouvertes vous avez les compétences vous
avez le talent allez-y et ne vous
laissez pas impressionner ou empêcher ou
détourner de votre volonté de de de de
faire d'agir d'urer dans ces domaineslà
au prétexte que ce sont des secteurs
encore aujourd'hui plutôt accaparé par
les par les garçons mais il faut
également que l'école veille à vous
donner toutes les chances d'y accéder et
que ensuite
dans la poursuite de vos parcours
professionnels à ce moment-là ce soit
les secteur professionnel eux même et
les entreprises qui vous prémunissent
contre les risques d'inégalité inégalité
salariale inégalité d'accès aux
professions et au risque de de de
violence sexuelle et sexiste qui
évidemment constitue un obstacle majeur
et on le voir encore aujourd'hui à un
exercice
serein normal dirais-je de de l'ensemble
des professions donc voilà ne vous
empêchez pas et ne croyez jamais jamais
que vous n'avez pas les compétences
merci agnas nous passons la parole à
Éric d'unquéant qui est derrière le
prompteur et puis qui va peut-être
prendre les questions donc du du fil
twitch bonjour à toutes et à tous donc
je vais passer la parole à Douglas
drefus qui est notre modérateur twitch
et qui a déjà relevé quelques questions
bonjour alors nous avons une première
question doit-on instaurer des quotas
pour réduire les inégalités très
volontiers moi je suis favorable au
quotas et je pense qu'en effet c'est une
mesure qui
peut faire peur mais qui d'un autre côté
a des effets positifs et des impact
assez immédiat on le voit d'ailleurs
dans un certain nombre de domaines comme
par exemple en politique ou dans le
secteur économique à partir du moment où
on a imposé des quotas par exemple dans
les conseils d'administration des des
grandes entreprises la loi RX1 tout
récemment a également imposé des des
quotas à atteindre progressivement je
rassure tout le monde dans les Comex des
entreprises privées à partir du moment
où on fixe un cap avec un temps
raisonnable pour atteindre cet objectif
on on voit très vite que
ces ces règles compose ont des effets
ont des impacts mesurables et et très
positifs alors dans le secteur culturel
et artistique finalement sans le dire
complètement en tout cas pas sous cette
forme on a nous-même
euh considérer que le quota de 50 %
c'est un peu ce que je disais tout à
l'heure devait être atteint à partir du
moment où vous avez plus de 50 % de
femmes dans le champ du ministère de la
Culture rien n'empêche qu'on retrouve ce
même pourcentage à la tête des
institutions et c'est vers quand je vous
disais qu'on avait aujourd'hui atteint à
peu près 43 % de femmes à la tête des
établissements publics le même
pourcentage 42 43 % de de femmes à la
tête des directions régionales des
Affaires Culturelles alors qu'elle
n'était que 25 % il y a encore 5 ou 6
ans c'est que on s'est bien fixé cette
objectif quantitatif alors on l'appelle
quota on l'pp on l'appelle objectif
quantitatif peu importe mais en tout cas
se dire
que on a besoin d'indicateurs de mesures
qui nous permettent d'évaluer
quantitative
le résultat des politiques menées par
sinon effectivement on pourra toujours
déclarer qu'on est favorable à l'égalité
si on n'est pas capable de le mesurer en
chiffre ça ne sert à rien et donc en
effet oui les quotas la volonté
d'atteindre un objectif quantifié en
matière de d'égalité mais peut-être
demain de diversité je pense que c'est
infiniment souhaitable nous avons une
autre question pensez-vous qu'un jour la
parité et l'égalité deviendront un
acquis définitif non un acquis sans
doute mais définitif non parce que l'un
des la vigilance s'impose à tout moment
en tout lieu en tout temps et on le voit
d'ailleurs malheureusement
dans beaucoup d'exemples qui sont
extrêmement décourageants quand on voit
que ce qu'on pensait être un acquis
définitif le droit des femmes à disposer
de leur corps le par exemple le droit à
l'avortement peut-être aujourd'hui en
2023 remis en cause et remis en cause ou
mis en cause pas dans des pays
complètement éloigné de de nos valeurs
démocratiques d'égalité ça peut être aux
États-Unis ça peut être dans des pays
européens de de de de l'Est de l'Europe
qui sont pas si éloignés de de nous
quand on pense qu'aujourd'hui le droit à
l'avortement peut être remis en question
c'est bien une illustration du fait que
finalement rien n'est jamais acquis un
autre exemple qui nous ramène à nos
secteurs culturels et même à à la
communication vous vous souvenez sans
doute que au moment de la pandémie ENF
rembobinons un peu le film on avait non
sans mal mais de manière régulière
atteint un pourcentage de femmes
expertes entre guillemets se produisant
enfin appelé à intervenir sur les
plateaux de de télévision un pourcentage
qui avait bien progressé et LARCOM en
tient un compte extrêmement précis dans
son propre baromètre de de l'égalité on
avait atteint pas loin de 30
% dans les années 2017-28 alors qu'on
parlait on partait de beaucoup plus bas
il y avait eu des mesures prises en
disant mais écoutez les experts il y a
des femmes très compétente en matière de
d'industrie de santé de de diplomatie
et cetera dans tous les domaines vous
les trouvez cherchez-les vous les
trouvez il y a eu des d'ailleurs des des
des outils mis en place notamment le
site les experts qui répertorient toute
une série de femmes extrêmement
compétentes dans tous ces domaineslà qui
est mis à la disposition des
journalistes en leur disant ben voilà
plutôt que de recourir à votre carnet
d'adresse qui ne contient que des noms
d'hommes allez donc voir sur ce site et
chercher les femmes compétentes mais
donc ça avait donné des des résultats et
puis d'un coup d'un seul pandémie covid
confinement et d'une manière
spectaculaire les femmes ont disparu
purement et simplement des plateaux de
télévision et on n plus donné la parole
dans tous les secteurs hein de la santé
de la sécurité et cetera et cetera qu'à
des hommes au point que nous avons euh
confié à une députée Céline Calvez le
soin d'élaborer un rapport sur cette
question de la disparition des experts
au moment de la crise et comment faire
en sorte que d'un pourcentage de 35 % on
soit passé à moins de 10 % de femmes sur
les plateaux parce qu'il y avait crise
mais pourquoi les femmes sont tout aussi
compétentes en matière de santé de
sécurité publique que les hommes
simplement on les on ne les avait plus
invité et donc on ne les a plus vu donc
ce cette question de la
réversibilité je pense qu'il faut qu'on
se la pose à tout moment en considérant
finalement que les acquis durement
obtenus durement atteints
sont en tout cas susceptibles d'être
remis en cause d'où une une vigilance de
tous les instants nous avons une autre
question sur le cinéma après les Palmes
d'Or décerné très récemment au
réalisatrice française Julia du Corneau
et Justine Triet est-ce que vous pensez
que ces succès vont aider la carrière
des jeunes femmes réalisatrices en
France de manière durable c'est une
grande victoire et on l' tellement
attendu tellement attendu parce que
depuis Jane Campion qu'il avait d qu'il
avait partagé sa PAL parce que toute
seule elle n'aurait pas pu l'obtenir on
avait rien eu et c'était quand même une
catastrophe de considérer que à ce
niveau-là de visibilité dans la
reconnaissance de la qualité
professionnelle bah il ne s'était rien
passé de depuis cette cette palme
attribué à Jane Campion donc le fait que
Julia du courourneud d'une part puis
Justine tri et puis d'autres prix
remportés dans des festivals
complètement prestigieux que ce soit à
Venise que ce soit à
Berlin attribué donc à des femmes ça a
jeté un une lumière c'est le cas de le
dire particulière sur ce talent
extraordinaire des femmes réalisatrices
auxquelles on avait donné les moyens de
tourner leurs film parce que c'est ça
finalement comment primer des films qui
ne se sont pas fait parce qu'on a
empêché les réalisatrices enfin on a
empêché pas humilitary mais on n pas
donné aux réalisatrices le moyen de les
tourner donc oui grande victoire mais
toujours pareil toujours cette méfiance
et cette crainte de la réversibilité il
faut poursuivre le mouvement il faut
faire en sorte on le disait tout à
l'heure qu'on passe de 25 ou 26 % de
réalisatrice à 35 40 45 % pourquoi pas
50 % donc plus il y aura de films
tournés par des femmes plus il y aura de
Chan que ces films d'une qualité
certaine au moins équivalente au films
tournés par des hommes soit reconnu
primé salué au niveau national
international et
également qu'il rencontre comme on le
dit dans le jargon du cinéma qu'il
rencontre leur public parce que plus il
y aura de films tournés par des femmes
plus il y aura de chances que le plus
grand nombre de spectateurs et de
spectatrices les les voient donc je
pense que c'est un élément de de très
belle visibilité mais qu'en même temps
ça doit s'accompagner ce mouvement de
reconnaissance de d'action peut-être
moins visible plus souterrain mais
néanmoins essentiel sur l'accès des
femmes à la capacité de créer et au
moyens de de créer on arrive à la
dernière question de de ce bloc comment
peut-on agir contre les inégalités pour
la diversité en tant qu'étudiant alors
il faut pas faire peser sur vous enfin
sur les étudiantes et les étudiants une
responsabilité trop grande alors déjà le
premier niveau de réponse c'est vous me
direz c'est assez évident mais peut-être
qu'il faut le rappeler parce que dans
nos écoles en tout cas je sais pas chez
vous comment ça se passe mais dans nos
écoles euh culture on constate encore
beaucoup de cas de par exemple de
violence sexuelle et sexiste entre
étudiante et étudiants donc déjà ne
serait-ce que faire en sorte de d'éviter
ces comportements et ces dérapages qui
sont quand même des délits pénaux hein
il faut le le rappeler c'est déjà le
premier niveau de garantie d'un
environnement de de travail et d'études
qui soit serein pour chacune et pour
chacun et puis
euh on peut également imaginer que des
étudiantes des étudiants jouent à un
certain moment de leurs études sans
vouloir trop en rajouter sur leur
responsabilité un rôle de mentor et un
rôle de d'accompagnement de conseil pour
celles et ceux qui débutent dans le
cursus d'étude voire même parce qu'on a
des cas qui sont très intéressants de
d'étudiantes et d'étudiants qui
accompagnent des actions dans les
établissements scolaires pour expliquer
en quoi consistent les études qu'il
qu'il et elle poursuivent afin d'inciter
des des élèves je sais pas en seconde en
première en terminale qui risque de ne
pas penser que ces études-là sont faites
pour elle et pour eux donc peut-être que
ce rôle de de de qui permet de véhiculer
un une image positive et ouverte des des
cursus que les étudiantes et les
étudiants poursuivent elles-mêm et
eux-mêmes ça peut être également un rôle
un rôle positif de parler des études
qu'on qu'on suit dans la perspective de
métier dans le domaine de la culture des
médias de la communication en faisant en
sorte que euh quand on est plus jeune et
quand on est plutôt dans le dans le
périmètre scolaire on se dit que
finalement oui c'est possible aussi et
que on peut y y accéder donc voilà c'est
peut-être ça peut vous paraître comment
dire modeste mais ce serait déjà ce
serait déjà beaucoup parce que sur les
étudiantes et les étudiants pèse quand
même beaucoup beaucoup de comment dire
de contrainte de crainte parfois de
l'avenir de l'insertion professionnelle
et donc il faudrait pas non plus trop
peut en rajouter je pense que nous avons
épuisé les les questions il nous reste à
vous remercier cher agès s de nous avoir
rendu visite je crois qu'on peut vous
remercier très chaleureusement mais non
merci à vous non non non merci à vous et
je vous assure je veux quand même dire
un dernier mot vous dire que ce ne sont
pas des combats faciles mais que ce sont
des combats essentiels et que ce sont de
beaux combats donc si chacune et chacun
d'entre vous qui êtes présent ici ce
soir qui nous verront peut-être plus
tard en direct ou en différé chacune et
chacun se convain de sa responsabilité
personnelle particulière dans la mise en
valeur de ces enjeux fondamentaux de
diversité et d'égalité je peux vous dire
qu'on aura pas complètement moi
certainement pas mais vous peut-être non
plus on n'ura pas perdu notre temps ce
soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci